bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour je vous
enjoins j'ouvre bonjour bonjour bon
alors pardon de vous déranger pendant le
week-end je vous retient pas longtemps
mais j'ai quelque chose à vous raconter
j'ai quelque chose à vous annoncer même
je vous en avais déjà parlé il ya
quelques temps
hélas cette fois maintenant c'est bon
c'est le moment je peux tout vous
raconter donc voilà toute l'histoire
je vous avais parlé de mes projets de
rentrée de façon un petit peu lointaines
comme ça on y est donc je peux vous dire
de quoi il s'agit puisque ça va
commencer très bientôt ça va commencer
le 15 septembre dimanche 15 septembre
alors ça sera pas sur des tc 1
mais vous allez voir que vous n'allez
pas trop être perdus quand même ce
projet c'est une émission que j'ai créée
fin que j'ai créé avec plein de gens
parce qu'on crée jamais rien tout seul
est évidemment et c'est une émission que
j'aime vraiment vraiment beaucoup
c'est une émission pour laquelle je me
suis baladé un petit peu partout en
france et même jusqu'en belgique
voyez un peu le truc et c'est une série
de rencontres avec des gens qui ont
quelque chose de particulier on va dire
en lien avec la santé
évidemment vous ne connaissez maintenant
la leur la plupart du temps mais pas
seulement je ne vous parle pas mais vous
verrez qu'il ya aussi d'autres trucs
en tout cas c'est des gens qui m'ont
invité chez eux pendant toute une
journée donc j'ai pas fait toute la
journée avec eux sans savoir du tout à
la base qui êtes admis connaître leur
histoire donc c'est des vraies
rencontres authentiques
on a beaucoup discuté c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment des bobos moment moi j'ai
adoré et j'ai vraiment hâte que vous
voyez ça alors pas de panique un j'ai
passé toute la journée avec eux mais
l'émission ne va pas durer 24 heures par
la magie du montage
on a commencé tout ça et qu'est ce qui
va se passer écoutez on se balade comme
j'ai dit on discute
il me raconte
leur vie ils me racontent leur passion
ils me racontent leur leur bonheur leurs
difficultés ils me racontent un petit
peu tout ce qui fait la vie de tout un
chacun mais vu de leurs fenêtres à eux
avec leur fameuse particularités et
l'objectif c'est de se rendre compte moi
d'abord et puis vous ensuite que on est
toutes et tous les mêmes
d'ailleurs c'est le nom de l'émission
[Musique]
sept mois confiance ça a été à chaque
fois des rencontres vraiment
extraordinaire incroyable des moments
marrant d maman cool des moments sérieux
où on apprend des choses on comprend des
choses où ils me parlent de leur passion
où ils m'apprennent même à faire des
trucs comme des coudreaux barré en
voilier par exemple voilà donc on a fait
plein de trucs on a pas mal discuté
aussi et j'espère que quand vous
regarderez ça vous fera comme moi
j'espère que vous allez comprendre
des trucs à apprendre des trucs que ça
va j'ai pas démystifier des trucs
dédramatiser vous inspirer et surtout
vous faire comprendre que ben on est de
toute façon tous et tout différend est
différente mais qu' on est en même temps
toutes et tous les mêmes d'où le
toujours le le nom pour cette très belle
aventure j'ai travaillé avec les
abordiez les abords du que vous
connaissez sans doute par exemple pour
sa série g record sur youtube mais aussi
pour plein d'autres trucs parce qu'elle
fait plein de trucs
moi j'avais vraiment très envie de
travailler avec les a
parce que je trouve qu'elle a ce talent
rare de montrer ce qui touche à l'humain
et alain team de façon à la fois très
belle et sans pathos parce que c'était
vraiment de moi la façon dont j'avais
envie de rendre compte de c2c de ces
rencontres rendre compte de ses
rencontres ses jolies donc acté en ce
qui me concerne c'est complètement
réussi je suis ravi mais bah vous me
direz évidemment ce que vous vous en
pensez
concrètement comment ça va se passer je
vous ai dit ça va se passer ici sur dtc
dans un premier temps ce dimanche 15
septembre dès 11 heures parce que ce
sera à 11 heures vous allez pouvoir
budget 1 comme on dit les sept premiers
épisodes il ya eu dix rencontres
au total la vous allez avoir les sept
premiers épisodes sur france tv slash
sur leurs plateformes
il y aura aussi le premier épisode sur
leur chaîne youtube dont je vous affiche
l'adresse est évidemment je vous remets
tout les liens nécessaires en
descriptions et puis ensuite ce sera une
vidéo par semaine le dimanche à 11
heures sur la chaîne youtube de slash tv
slash un autre sage cause je vous remets
tout les liens et puis sur france tv
slash aussi petit résumé une saison 10
épisode ça commence ce dimanche 15 sur
france tv slash ce sera ensuite à par
semaine sur la chaîne youtube de france
tv slash les dimanches à 11h 10
rencontres jusque j'ai adoré mener des
discussions des rigolades des trucs un
peu plus sérieux un peu plus lourd mais
toujours de façon très légère et très
très intimiste ouvert et j'ai adoré
faire ça j'espère que vous allez autant
adoré le regarder évidemment si vous
avez des questions via les commentaires
et puis si vous voulez vous tenir au
courant je mettrais régulièrement des
annonces ou des explications et c'est
sûr mais réseaux sociaux donc twitter
facebook un stage vous mais aussi tous
les liens dans la description comme ça
que vous avez tout ce qu'il vous faut
rendez vous ce dimanche 15 septembre à
11 heures
et puis tous les dimanches la suivant
sur france tv slash et sur youtube pour
cette nouvelle émission que j'adore
c'est mon bébé toutes et tous les mêmes
en attendant mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous dire on peut pas me voir
autrement que par mon handicap et nous
avons un design de quelques qualités et
tu pourras plus comme s'il y avait deux
mois il y avait le mot andy et le monde
valide
[Musique]
bon alors raconté un petit peu c'est moi
je sais absolument rien
je suis né sans main gauche les avants
19 ans et un mois plus tard j'ai perdu
s'avère que il ya eu une lésion
cérébrale que tout ce qui touche à la
motricité défense est dur ça m'empêchera
pas de vivre ma vie mais voilà découvert
le rugby en fauteuil
annie écrit par entre dessinatrice j'ai
la vibration du photo puis sommes en
fait quand ils se déplacent en fait
arrêter de nous prendre tout simplement
pour des handicapés prenez nous pour ce
que l'on est et pas parce que l'on a
[Musique]